kenny
is in odessa texas hi kenny how are you
good thanks for taking my call today
dave and chris uh my question for you
today
my girlfriend and i bought a house two
years ago we paid cash for it
she paid three quarters of it i paid one
quarter of it
and we've we've drawn up paperwork if we
die if we split up you know how the
money is giving to our grown children
and she's recommended that she buy me
out my part of it that way i can put in
an investment account get it growing
on top of my other 401k in investment
but i'm worried you know because then my
name wouldn't be on the house i wouldn't
be an owner i would be a tenant so i was
going to get your input on that
um the data that we have
from people who build wealth don't
do it the way you're doing it okay
um and so the data that we have from
millionaires is
they have um i you know
north of eighty percent of them we
studied ten thousand millionaires in
chris's book
uh everyday millionaires north of eighty
percent of them uh
were in lockstep
complete shared goals with their spouse
we found almost none of them
being people living with someone they
weren't married to
that's the actual data points and so i'm
kind of a practical guy in that respect
um and so you may want to reconsider
your whole model as my point
because if you if you were married and
you both and you had a big pile of
investments and you had a paid for house
you wouldn't be dealing with all this
crap you're spending a lot of your
energy running sideways
mm-hmm kenny i'm curious
go ahead kenny uh she's she's wealthy i
mean
she's she's got plenty of money for
retirement she gets alimony every month
i have a great career i make six figures
uh i've got plenty in my 401k plenty
there like say we just
bought this house together this is the
only thing we have together all of our
debts are paid off and everything
and that's all we have together but like
i said she was just wanting to buy me
out just
that way there's no hassle in the end if
something happens to one of our both of
us you know we travel a lot and stuff
and it's just easier you know it's in
her will that her child is no hassle at
the end of the relationship either
you're just gone
right yeah that's right that's what i'm
worried about well
and and it sounds like to me she's not
wanting to get married because the
alimony set up true we neither one want
to get married we've both been married
before and we
and we like our relationship the way it
is we've been together almost five years
and like
we just moved in two years ago so she
brought to you the idea of buying you
out of this house
we were just talking about investments
and everything and yeah she just brought
it up she goes hey would it be easier
because we're doing our wheels again and
stuff like that it would it would be
cleaner be easier it would be much
cleaner oh
okay you don't think there's a problem
with my name not being on the house you
know
the problem is you don't live there if
she don't want you to
right and so you don't see that as a
real problem though that's a
relationship issue that's not a
financial issue
right if you want to if you want to own
some real estate you can go buy some
real estate
elsewhere as rental property right but
when you don't own the home when you
don't have any ownership rights at all
to the home you live in
when the owner says leave you get to
leave
good point there's your attendant that's
a but that's a relationship issue
know you know you but you just outlined
what your all's model was and how you're
approaching this
um i'm telling you there's very few data
points that say that leads to prosperity
um it usually doesn't as a matter of
fact so
um uh i'd be a little bit worried she
wants to buy you out
just out of the blue telltale sign
don't spend that i wanna buy you out
get out we're just teasing you
we're just teasing you kenny sort of
hang on to the money kitty
no i would do it it would because it
would clean up every wood
it would clean up everything
you're just mean hogan i'm telling you
you're mean hit the button you're a
big mean man